- Yo, yo, it's your boy Jeezy.
I'm here with Bleacher Report,
and we playin' Start,
Bench, Cut—in that order.
Let's get it.
Start the Moonwalk.
♪♪♪ Upbeat music ♪♪♪
The middle one, cut that.
We're gonna bench the
Dougie for a lil' bit.
Start tequila. Benching
whiskey. Cutting vodka.
♪♪♪ upbeat music ♪♪♪
We startin' pizza.
We cuttin' wings.
And we benchin' seven-layer dip.
Nah.
Vegan.
Shit.
♪♪♪ Upbeat music ♪♪♪
Tom Brady's gonna retire pretty soon,
so we're gonna bench him.
We gotta cut Tiger Woods. I'm sorry.
We gotta start Serena Williams.
She's a, she's a very strong woman.
Queen. She's dope.
[Laughing]
I saw what you did there.
We're startin' all three.
All three of those are classic albums.
"Tha Carter III" was one
of Wayne's best albums.
Other than "Tha Carter I," cuz
"Tha Carter I" is my
favorite Lil Wayne album.
"Get Rich Or Die Tryin'" is 50's
best body of work, period.
"Blueprint," I grew up on that,
so I already know what that is.
It's gonna be hard to break those down,
but that's a great question.
I'm here with Bleacher Report,
and I'm talking about my new
sports agency, Agency 99.
And all you young athletes know
to come holla at the big homie.
Let me help you get right, baby.
We gonna build them finances,
broaden that portfolio.
We gonna get you right.
Agency 99, that's what we do.